movember is an annual event involving
the growing of mustaches during the
month of november to raise awareness for
men's health issues like prostate cancer
finley kia who are the sponsors of this
segment are doing their part to help
here to tell us more is byron clemaski
from finleykia and angela van brackle
from american cancer society welcome you
guys ah thanks for having us okay you
got a new look here
i did i uh cheated a little bit this
year and i already had a beard so i i
got my mustache on day one herb
what are you guys doing at finley key to
help out such a great thing you're doing
so the biggest thing is we love
supporting charities this one's near and
dear to my heart i was diagnosed two
years ago
with prostate cancer and luckily i'm in
remission and all that amazing that's
awesome i don't feel like a lot of men
get their checkups do the awareness and
that's kind of why i want to partner up
with the american cancer society and
maybe
so get some more awareness out there
what people are doing we want people to
do to go down to the dealership you guys
have an amazing lineup of cars we're
taking selfies taking photos and posting
them online post them online if you
cannot or your husband doesn't want you
i've got a question
you guys have these guys
or you can just go onto our website and
we've got a link on there you can just
donate directly and what happens when
someone does the picture you guys make a
donation on their behalf 25 that's great
absolutely angelo at what age should men
start getting screened so if they are
low risk 50 if they have a first degree
family member with prostate cancer 45 if
they have two or more first-degree
family members so like a father or
brother um then they suggest at age 40.
so so byron could you get personal with
you did you go get screened in advance
how did you how did you so my father was
diagnosed okay years and years ago which
started the mustache and uh the doctor
looked me straight in the face and says
you're gonna get it wow so every six
months i went and i did my psa levels
which is a simple blood test
super easy and all of a sudden my psa
levels went up
and then uh boom we caught it early and
early detection is key that's the key
here now is that the main for a test
that the test you're done with what was
it called the php psa and so that's a
simple test that people can do it's a
simple blood test um so it's the the
first layer in testing and then once the
the levels get elevated they look at
more um invasive testing but it's a very
easy problem
let's break this down okay as a guy here
okay so for the first test is that
simple blood test yes that's an easy
blood test all you have to do super easy
and it's life changing we're seeing it
is life changing right here absolutely
and then let's talk more about you guys
because what you're doing is really cool
so go down the dealership just get a
mustache get a mustache if you haven't
grown a mustache to have a mustache
and you're going to take a selfie in a
kia and by doing that we post you on
facebook and we're going to donate 25 to
a great cause if you purchase a car it's
even better we're going to donate
another 25 oh that's great buy a car and
extra money goes to help out there how
about the calls angela what does it mean
to you when finley kia comes to you and
say we want to do something to raise
awareness you know it's a great
partnership
here in nevada alone in 2021 it's
estimated about
2100 cases of prostate cancer will be
diagnosed and approximately 300 people
will die from it so with the pandemic we
had a 90 decline in screening so it's
very important that they're raising
awareness to this to get people back to
their doctor for that test and and
keeping an eye on things so the easier
we catch it the easier we can we can you
know treat it and just just to raise
that awareness and say hey there are
plenty of opportunities here um it's
just it's a great great aspect to work
with finley final question real quick
someone like myself wants to get tested
i just go see my doctor that's it simple
as that
i appreciate it thank you guys for those
mustaches you're gonna borrow this to
take part in finley kia's movember event
visit findlay kia at 5325 west sahara
they're amazing call them at
702-359-7447 or visit
findlaykia.com and don't forget to take
that selfie in one of their vehicles
with this mustache and donate 25
to the american cancer society las vegas
now we will